SUPREME COURT JUSTICES.
HE WANTS TO CHANGE THE FACE OF
THE COUNTRY FOR THE WORST.
JOINING NOW VICTOR DAVIS HANSON.
HE'S NOT REALLY HIDING HIS
AMBITIONS BUT YOU THINK ABOUT
THIS, THE GUY CAN IT RUN
SOUTH BEND, INDIANA, WELL WHICH
IS A DISASTER WHEN HE WAS MAYOR.
IS HE GOING TO DO TO THE
PRESIDENCY WHEN HE'S DONE TO AIR
TRAVEL THIS SUMMER?
>> I THINK HE WOULD.
THE PROBLEM WITH THE BIDEN
AGENDA IS THAT NOBODY LIKES WHAT
HE'S DOING.
HE'S DESTROYING THE COUNTRY AND
DOING EVERYTHING THAT THE HARD
LEFT WANTED.
HE'S FLOODING THE NAME OF
SOMEBODY WHO'D BE MORE ON THE
BORDER, CRIME, GAS.
THEY ARE WORSE THAN BIDEN.
IT MAY LOOK AT BIDEN AND HARRIS,
THEIR PERSONALITIES DON'T UPLIFT
THE AGENDA BECAUSE THEY ARE
INCOHERENT FOR VARIOUS REASONS
BUT YOU LOOK AT THEM, HE PULLS
EVEN WORSE WITH MINORITIES THAT
ARE TRYING TO ATTRACT.
IF THE RECORD WITH
TRANSPORTATION IT'S BEEN A
DISASTER.
AT THE HIGHWAY SYSTEM NOBODY CAN
AFFORD TO DRIVE.
THE AIRLINE INDUSTRY IS IN
SHAMBLES, IN THE PORT OF L.A.
COME AT THEIR SHIP STACKED UP TO
THE HORIZON.
WILD WEST TRAIN RAW THINGS IN
THE PORT.
HE TALKS ABOUT THE RACIST
ORIGINS OF THE FREEWAY SYSTEM OR
HE'S GOING TO DIVERSIFY THE
COCKPIT.
HE TALKS ABOUT THINGS THAT HAVE
NO RELEVANCE TO THE VOTERS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO HEAR ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE, TRANSGENDERRISM.
ABORTIONS.
THEY HAVE FOUR OR FIVE ISSUES
THERE CONCERNED ABOUT.
BUTTIGIEG WOULD MULTIPLY THE
PROBLEMS THAT THEY HAVE.
HE'S A PRODUCT OF THE
PROFESSIONAL CLASS THAT
APPRECIATES THE GLIBNESS, THE
SANCTIMONIOUS NEST, THE
SELF-RIGHTEOUSNESS, THEY LIKE
HIS REPORT TO YOU, BUT THAT WILL
NOT APPEAL TO ANYBODY ELSE.
>> Laura: HE WENT TO THE
ESSENCE FESTIVAL.
HE WENT TO THE ESSENCE FESTIVAL
AND IT WAS AN AMAZING TIME.
THAT'S WHAT CONSTITUTES OUTREACH
FOR HIM.
I MEAN, THAT'S JUST BAD.
IT'S IDIOTIC!
>> HE TALKS TO AMERICANS THE WAY
THAT JOE BIDEN TALKS TO LATINOS.
IT'S CONDESCENDING, FAKE, NOT
GENUINE AND PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
IT.
THAT'S WHY THEY VOTED
OVERWHELMINGLY IN THE PRIMARIES
TO REJECT THEM.
IT WASN'T BECAUSE HE WAS GAY,
IT'S BECAUSE HE WAS
SELF-RIGHTEOUS.
GLIB.
HE SET THE ACADEMIC LOUNGE ON
FIRE AND THEY LOVED IT.
BUT IT TRANSLATED AND IN THE
REAL WORLD HE'S JUST GOING TO
TAKE THAT LOSING AGENDA FURTHER
TO THE LEFT AND HE BRINGS NO
PERSONAL COUNTERWEIGHT.
IF I THINK HE'S MORE UNPOPULAR N
KAMALA.
>> Laura: DEMOCRATS JUST KEEP
THINKING THEY HAVE A MESSAGING
PROBLEM.
IF THEY HAD A DIFFERENT
MESSENGER, THE POLICIES WOULD GO
OVER IT.
BUT THEY HAVE A POLICY PROBLEM,
NOT NECESSARILY A MESSAGE
PROBLEM.
>> THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
BIDEN HAD INHERITED EVERYONE OF
TRUMP'S POLICIES AND LEFT IT
UNCHANGED AND PLAGIARIZED IT
LIKE IT'S HIS.
SAID IT WAS HIS AND WE WOULD BE
TALKING TO WHAT EVE RIGOROUS
79-YEAR-OLD HE IS RIGHT NOW.
LOOK AT THE LOW INFLATION,
AFFORDABLE GAS, THE CRIME RATE
IS STILL LOW.
THE BORDER IS SECURE, BIDEN IS
79 AND HE DID ALL OF THIS.
IT'S NOT EVEN OF AGE, IT'S A
FORCE MULTIPLYING BUT IT'S THE
AGENDA.
HE MANAGED IN A YEAR AND A HALF
DESTROYED THE COUNTRY TO THE
EXTENT THAT A PRESIDENT CAN.
>> Laura: THE LEFT IS NOW
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE WORKING
CLASS HAS ABANDONED THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY, OR THE DEMOCRATS ABANDON
THE WORKING CLASS.
IN 20 SECONDS, CAN THE DEMOCRATS
IN A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME WHEN
THEM BACK?
>> NO, WE TALKED ABOUT THAT WITH
THE VIRGINIA ELECTIONS.
YOU SAID THEY WEREN'T WENT TO
CHANGE, THEY'RE GOING T